Film Courage: Did you feel it was impossible to make
Hollywood movies because you're in
Sweden? You didn't know anyone in the
film industry? David F. Sandberg, Filmmaker (a.k.a. PonySmasher on YouTube) It felt very far away,
very distant yes. I mean what you
started seeing him especially the
YouTube you started seeing that there
was hope like like Fede Alvarez who
directed the Evil Dead remake and Don't
Breathe you know he made a short film
Panic Attack that went viral. That's how
he got into Hollywood. Same with you know
and even scary you made mama made the
short film mama made the big film mom
and now he's done 8mm you know all these
things so you know you started seeing
like either like it's not necessarily
that distant but you know I mean lot
that we have this sort of plan or what
what our thinking was that we'd make
these skull shorts to show the film
Institute that hey look we're doing some
cool stuff here give us some money
and if we got some money we would do
longer shorts and maybe with that we
could you know get some attention and
maybe do like a Swedish feature or two
and then maybe that will get some
attention from Hollywood some you know
way down the road weirdly enough that we
got to skip all that because we made
this short and somebody was straight to
Hollywood so we never made anything
professional in Sweden really and we
never got to know the Swedish film
community or what that's like
were there unspoken rules that you
quickly learned just from being here
just things they don't really tell you
that are just protocol yeah I mean there
was a lot to learn coming here because I
didn't really know how film set works
like watch a ton of like behind the
scenes and listen to commentaries on
laser disc and then DVD but yeah there
was still little things I didn't know
like you couldn't find out from there
and one of them was like I didn't know
when to say action so when I was
interviewing a first ad for for the
position of first ad I
I would ask him like so when do I
actually say action because I've heard
like there's sound speed and all these
things and and it's yeah it sounds being
all and and when then when the camera
operator says that he's ready then it's
then you can say action but yeah there
was a lot to learn just how it worked on
a film set like interviewing a script
supervisor same thing there's like I was
basically just asking what do you do
like what is a script supervisor but
what I found was that yeah there was a
lot to learn with everything around it's
how things work and what's how they're
supposed to do but the actual filmmaking
itself feels like it never changes
whether you have no money or all the
money in the world it's still the same
sort of thinking of how to shoot
something how to tell a story so the
rest of it is just things you have to
learn to navigate but the core of it
feels like it's the same which is good
because it feels like okay that then I
know kind of what I'm doing and sorry
you said previously that you were
influenced more by American cinema
then it was Swedish than or not yeah I
mean growing up it was yeah American
movies American TV shows lots of like
Spielberg and James Cameron and John
Carpenter Wes Craven and just stuff like
that because that means Sweden it's a
small country and even the sort of more
populous movies are kind of you know
compared to American movies they're very
small and they're not exciting
especially not when you're a little kid
and you want like spectacle and cool
stuff and and you know it's also just a
bigger pool of talent just because it's
such a big country and a lot of people
come here to make movies and things
that's you can get more interesting
stuff full on at a time so Bergman films
didn't really intrigue you I do yes no I
good I do love Bergman and like Lars von
Trier Gaspar Nui I really like which you
know they do very interesting movies and
then
times especially Gaspar no way like I
don't think he's made something that's
truly for me but it's I'll see anything
he does because I always find it
interesting you know so I I do like all
kinds of movies and I you know I had a
period of my life where I was very much
into just like art house and indie and
stuff like that then I kind of watching
a lot of those movies I kind of because
you you know when you get into that
phase of your life you're like oh
Hollywood movies are not that great
because they're so formulaic and
everything is all the same and then when
you watch a lot of art house movies you
start realizing well it's kind of a
formula to this to there are they're
just sort of different tropes and
different you know languages but it's
kind of the same thing there so then
it's sort of you return to the American
movies or Hollywood movies as well and
now I kind of like everything but yeah
what I like doing is quite commercial I
guess at the time but I you know maybe
at some point I'll do something more art
house as well and see what that's like
you